The fuck did he get reelected as a nice,
Connecticut's a bulletin stuff cause it's tribalism.
You're going to vote blue in Connecticut,
but how would,
how would they accept him as their candidate?
Because he got,
I think it came out once he was the candidate.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
That's a big one man.
Yet is stolen valor and all that stuff.
I mean,
forget about what Brian Williams did.
That's way bigger.
I get shit for having shaved sides of my hair.
People were like,
is that's the Nazi?
No,
they're like,
is that stolen valor?
And I'm like,
no,
I've gotten that.
Yes.
Come on a haircut.
This is on politifact.com about it.
Um,
he listened to Marine Corps reserves in 1970 until then,
five deferments had kept him out of the war,
getting a coveted slot in the reserves,
reduced the chance of battlefield deployment Blumenthal.
Went through basic training and served six years in the Washington DC area in
Connecticut as Connecticut's Attorney General Blumenthal,
regularly attended Memorial Day parades and other events that recognize soldiers
and veterans in New York.
Times wrote and May 17th,
2010 that in 2003 Blumenthal had spoken at a rally supporting troops overseas.
Though newspaper reported that Blumenthal said when we returned,
we saw nothing like this.
That was a comparison with soldiers who came back from Vietnam Blumenthal
repeatedly repeated a similar line in 2007 Memorial Day parade in Milford,
Connecticut and at a 2008 ceremony for veterans and senior citizens.
Blumenthal said,
we have learned something important since the days that I served in Vietnam.
Ooh,
Yup.
And then look at the very bottom line.
Although I did not serve in Vietnam,
I've seen firsthand the effects of military action.
Aha.
Well that's cool story,
Bro.
He's alive.
Why do you think firsthand?
Yeah.
Well that's,
he said,
we have learned something important since the days that I served in Vietnam.
If they quoted that and that's a f f he said that a 2008 ceremony,
that's a liar.
Yeah.
I mean that's just,
that's stolen valor,
but you know,
it's,
it's a lie as much as it's stolen valor cause he does have military service,
which,
you know what I mean?
He was a part of the reserves,
which is an important part of the military.
There's no,
I mean,
you don't want to diminish that,
but lying about having actually been in Vietnam is it's as close to stolen valor
as you can get with actually being a veteran.
Yeah,
yeah.
Right.
Yeah.
It's like shady,
shady,
but they're dirty people.
They're dirty people.
Yeah,
of course.
It's a dirty business.
Horrible,
horrible people.
So that's why when people are like,
venerating these monsters,
I'm like,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
These people are horrible.
Just doing that,
just doing that alone.
That's what's hilarious that he got through though.
Oh yeah.
It's,
it's funny when people can get away with,
does he ever said,
I'm sorry.
Shouldn't have said that.
What'd he say?
Oops.
I did it again in a spoke and made mistakes and I have,
I have misspoken
about my service and I regret and I take full responsibility.
You don't feel responsibility means resigning?
Does it?
If you're taking,
what does responsibility mean?
If there's no consequences?
Well,
that's a good question.
the consequences are public shaming.
Maybe he is the best person for the job despite the fact that he lied a decade
ago.
I still don't know what responsibility means in this context.
I've taken responsibility.
I remember gender.
I was,
I had found a mine,
Janet Reno,
when Waco happened in all those kids died and all the sheep say Janet Reno was a
friend of yours.
No,
a friend of mine was talking about January.
no,
no.
I knew Janet Reno was pals with Janet Reno was a friend of mine.
You're no,
denora.
Janet Reno.
Um,
and she went on TV after Waco and all those people died and she goes,
this is my fault.
I take full responsibility.
And my friend's like,
then you should be in jail.
If you are responsible for murdering dozens of people getting killed,
you should be in jail.